ce the guardian
der spiegel hugo
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h tron pour décrypter les
grands titres de l'actualité de la
journée au sommaire de ce mardi vie
février est il possible de faire avancer
les négociations de paix russie ukraine
emmanuel macron la firme alors qu'il
poursuit sa tournée diplomatique après
moscou hier le président français s'est
rendu ce matin à kiev puis berlin en ce
moment nouvelle conférence de presse
commune en ce moment même avec le
chancelier allemand qui sera suivie de
discussions privées de son côté le
kremlin tempère et dit attendre des
réponses de l'otan et les états unis sur
les questions sécuritaires alors le
locataire de l'élysée peut-il vraiment
faire avancer les négociations de paix
le débat est ouvert
autre dossier brûlant qui divise le
nucléaire iranien reprise aujourd'hui
des négociations à vienne en autriche où
siège l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique
1 8e ronde de pourparlers décisif
dernière ligne droite pour sauver
l'accord de 2015 pour les etats-unis une
entente avec téhéran est en vue et
urgente washington qui on le rappelle
assez retiré en 2018 sous la présidence
de donald trump de ce texte conclu trois
ans plus tôt un accord pour empêcher
l'iran de se doter de la bombe atomique
au sommaire à 21h une nouvelle sortie
médiatique d'eric très critiquée selon
lui les hlm sont des terres
d'islamisation du pays des propos
stigmatisants et jugé à mensonges et par
l'union sociale pour l'habitat qui
décide de porter plainte contre le
candidat à la présidentielle alors
énième provocation ou véritable constat
dans les quartiers en france
l'islamisation les villes en font l ac
on attend vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme d'ayrté france
[Musique]
après moscou et kiev 1 emmanuel macron
et donc à berlin ce soir un président
français qui espère bien jouer le rôle
de médiateur dans la crise ukrainienne
on en parle avec un autre grand reporter
régis le sommier
bonsoir régissent le président français
que s'entretenir avec le chancelier
allemand et présidents polonais ils sont
d'ailleurs en train de donner une
conférence de presse commune elle vient
de débuter elle sera suivie de
discussions privées quels sont les
enjeux de cette nouvelle rencontre
aujourd'hui
alors il ya deux choses qui sont un port
très importante dans cette rencontre
c'est d'abord le véritable marathon
diplomatique
auquel vient de se livrer emmanuel
macron donc on l'a dit à rencontrer
vladimir poutine le emmanuel macron le
premier dirigeant occidental de premier
plan à avoir rencontré le président
russe à s'être frotté je dirai au
président russe vous savez au bout de
cette longue table qu'on a vu hier dans
le but n'est pas vraiment de mettre le
convive à l'aise mais néanmoins emmanuel
macron a passé cinq heures avec vladimir
poutine il dit avoir obtenu de la part
du dirigeant russe des garanties qu'il
n'y aura pas d' escalade supplémentaire
dans la crise en tout cas que cette
escalade ne viendra pas du côté russe et
avoir des solutions concrètes pratiques
pour solutionner cette crise donc on
attend un petit peu parce que le il est
prévu évidemment que vladimir poutine
emmanuel macron devaient se parler à
nouveau après justement l'épisode kiev
c'est à dire la rencontre des manuels
macron avec le président terrain ce qui
cette fois qu'ils aient lieu aujourd'hui
et l'autre voilà l'autre
et c'est là où aujourd'hui l'épisode
berlin est très important puisque dans
deux dans le même temps olaf scholz le
chancelier allemand lui rentre tout
juste de washington où il a rencontré
les dirigeants américains évidemment
sur les mêmes thématiques sur la
thématique de la crise ukrainienne d'une
certaine mesure on avait vu jusqu'à
présent l'europe un petit peu laissé de
côté vous savez que juste depuis le
début de cette crise c'est surtout la
diplomatie russe contre la diplomatie
amérique
les les commandes par les sont engagées
entre les deux et comment l'europe a eu
l'impression d'avoir été tenu à l'écart
lien avec cette nouvelle initiative
d'emmanuel macro et de son côté celle de
la fiole c'est également qui a joué sa
part en allant aux états unis on peut
penser quand même que l'europe on
reprend la main sur ce dossier un
dossier qui la concerne au premier plan
puisque s'il ya une guerre en en ukraine
c'est un peu comme s'il y avait une
guerre en europe alors régis et une
conférence de presse extrêmement courte
beaucoup plus courte que celle d'hier
avec vladimir poutine puisqu'elle vient
de s'achever avant le disais quand même
des des
discussions privées la france la pologne
et l'allemagne sont unis pour préserver
la paix en europe voilà en substance ce
qui est ressorti de cette conférence de
presse est clair en tout cas des
entretiens avec olaf scholz lui même de
retour de washington avec finalement
quel message
alors collectionne la question c'était
évidemment le fameux oléoduc de gaz nord
stream ii vous savez qu'il n'est
toujours pas rentré en comment qui ne
touche pas au perreux opérant
aujourd'hui il n'y a toujours pas de gaz
qui qui qui circulent dans ce nouvel
oléoduc et évidemment les allemands ont
laissé alors les allemands sont divisés
sur cette question on sait que la fiole
c'est beaucoup plus pragmatique c'était
le grand argentier d'angela merkel qu'il
a été vice chancelier pendant une
pendant des années et par contre ça ça
comme on ministre des affaires
étrangères anna lena bareback qui fait
partie du parti des grünen est beaucoup
plus hostile à la russie et beaucoup lui
et a toujours été d'ailleurs hostiles à
la mise en place de ce pipeline
le nom de ce pipeline c'est à vous dire
à tel point que cette affaire est
extrêmement comment brûlante c'est que
il n'a même pas été prononcé pendant sa
conférence de presse par olaf scholz aux
états unis donc évidemment ça a été
l'enjeu des questions 2 2 comment des
discussions avec les américains les
américains essayant de faire pression
pour les allemands sur les allemands de
dire que si la russie envahi l'ukraine
et bien jamais ce 'pipeline' ne sera mis
en action et donc ça c'est un enjeu
économique un enjeu stratégique
également du livre en importance pour
l'allemagne est donc là il ya eu
effectivement les allemands qu'on a
senti au début de cette crise beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus sur la réserve par
exemple que l'otan ou que les etats-unis
vis-à-vis de la russie principalement à
cause de ces questions de relations
entre au sujet des hydrocarbures entre
la russie et l'allemagne merci beaucoup
régis le sommier alors je vous le disais
cette conférence de presse entre les
dirigeants polonais et allemands et
français vient de s'achever suivi
maintenant par des discussions privées
donc à berlin lors plus tôt dans la
journée emmanuel macron était à kiev où
il a rencontré son homologue ukrainien
2h30 des changes entre les deux
dirigeants pour tenter d'apaiser les
tensions entre l'ukraine et la russie un
rendez vous au lendemain d'un face à
face avec venir' poutine à moscou les
précisions de notre correspondante one
les roe dans la capitale russe
le président français était aujourd'hui
à kiev pour rencontrer son homologue
ukrainien au lendemain de son
déplacement au kremlin macron estime
qu'il existe des pistes vers la
désescalade détention dans l'est
ukrainien et comme il le disait déjà en
conférence de presse en compagnie de
bagnères poutine le règlement de cette
crise passe en grande partie par la mise
en oeuvre des accords de minsk locataire
de l'elysée qui nos passages pas tari
d'éloges sur la transition démocratique
de l'ukraine depuis huit ans l'ukraine
s'est déjà considérablement transformé
et ce chemin
résolument en avons parlé l'un et
l'autre je m'assois lequel il n'y a pas
de marche en arrière
le 26 janvier dernier les quatre pays
ont réaffirmé leur engagement à mettre
en oeuvre les accords de minsk qui ont
vocation à rendre l'ukraine son
intégrité territoriale
et qui trace le chemin vers la paix le
président ukrainien attachés à la
souveraineté de son pays ne s'est pas
étendu sur le sujet des accords de minsk
même s'il a laissé entendre qu'il
souhaitait qu'une rencontre au format
normandie et lieu dans un avenir proche
nous avons une plateforme de discussion
c'est le faire mais la normandie noms
sont contents de la rencontre de nos
sherpas qui va réaliser les jours
prochains s'il ya cette ouverture est
justement je pense qu'on aura la
rencontre des leaders et juste au moment
où on pourrait attendre manifester son
sujet et ce sera un vertueux les défis y
en a beaucoup on les appelle il y en a
beaucoup du côté du kremlin on estime
que la visite des manuels macron de la
veille n'est pas venu répondre aux
demandes russe de garanties de sécurité
la question de l'arrêt de l'extension
des frontières de l'otan crucial pour la
russie reste plus que jamais d'actualité
comme l'a réitéré le porte parole du
kremlin au lendemain de la rencontre
entre les présidents russe et français
comme vous le savez et hier il a été
souligné par le président que
malheureusement dans les réponses que
nous avons reçues de washington et de
l'otan il y a aussi des éléments
rationnels ils sont malheureusement
secondaire nous n'avons malheureusement
pas reçu de réponse sur les points
fondamentaux
c'est pourquoi cette question reste
ouverte au sens le plus large du terme
et reste la plus importante pour nous le
président a salué et remercié monsieur
macron d'avoir trouvé la possibilité de
venir à moscou et de poursuivre un
dialogue avec le président poutine la
recherche de solutions possibles à la
situation
et sur le terrain les tensions ne baisse
pas bien au contraire dimitri peskov dit
par exemple regretté l'afflux d'armement
au 6dans tôt vers l'ukraine cette même
ukraine qui effectuent des manoeuvres
pour tester les équipements reçus un
cercle vicieux qui ressemble davantage à
une escalade plutôt qu'à la désescalade
souhaitée par tous emmanuel macron qui
assure donc vouloir des solutions
concrètes voir des solutions concrètes
même à la crise ukrainienne est ce
vraiment le cas place à notre décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir sur
ce plateau emmanuel dupuy président de
l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe en soit m nl dupuis merci d'être
avec nous à nos côtés bruno noffs qui
historien spécialiste de la russie et
des pays de l'est bonsoir merci
également de nous accompagner ce soir la
conférence de presse éclair 1 vient de
s'achever à emmanuel dupuis apologue
allemagne france je découvre en même
temps le contenu dans sa durée environ
montre en main dix minutes nous allons
continuer à agir dans des objectifs
simples défendre les principes qui ont
fait notre europe ces trente dernières
années trouver des voies et des moyens
d'engager
les cheveux les moyens vers un pardon
parce qu'on me l'a écrit c'est pas
évident à lire les moyens importants
vers la russie pour différents formats
premier objectif éviter la guerre le
deuxième consolider et défendre à chaque
instant l'unité des européens et des
alliés très tourné sur l'europe l'unité
de l'europe est ce qu'on parle également
des gages qu'on pourrait donner à la
russie en tout cas ce que l'aide du
russie aussi demande en termes de
garanties de sécurité
déjà vous avez raison de mentionner le
symbole de la durée la rencontre entre
valimir putty mêmes macron a été
singulièrement longue en bilatéral mais
la conférence de presse a été dense la
deuxième conférence de presse à kiev
entre volodymyr zielinski et le
président mm macro a été beaucoup plus
courte il a d'ailleurs été question
aussi de relations bilatérales
pratiquement autant que de la question
des tensions d'ailleurs le président
volodymyr dans une spirale botté en
touche plusieurs fois côté il a été
interrogé sur ce qu'il attendait de la
désescalade et puis dix minutes comme
vous l'évoquez avec le président andrés
wood 1
le chancelier olaf scholz a néanmoins
vous avez mentionné en fait le paradoxe
de du phrasé ou du narratif des malades
macron 30 ans c'est pas l'union
européenne ces lois c est en fait on
joue constamment sur le paradoxe on
donnerait l'impression que c'était même
à contre plaisant du conseil de l'union
européenne qui a parlé avec lumières
routine c'est oublier un peu vite que
olaf scholz a parlé à jauldes hayden en
tant que président du g7 et que le
processus de normandie le format de
normandie le processus de minsk le
protocole de mise puisque c'est comme ça
qu'ils s'appellent depuis 2014 ainsi que
les rencontres
fadri latéral qui ont été évoqués
s'inscrivent tous dans le lot et c'est
donc en fait il faut avoir à l'esprit
que le président avait les yeux routine
le président mêmes macron le président
ukrainien est bien évidemment de chance
également et le président polonais parle
de la même chose mais en ne mettant pas
les mêmes organisations le président
mêmes macron a donné l'impression qu'il
parlait au nom des 30 pays membres de
l'otan il me semble que le secrétaire
général viennent stoltenberg n'a pas du
tout les mêmes doléances vis-à-vis de
moscou d'ailleurs ça a été évoqué par
dimitri peskov il ya quelques instants
donc je crois qu'on est encore dans ce
paradoxe mais en tout cas larchitecture
de paix et de sécurité de confiance le
rétablissement de la confiance il a été
beaucoup question de confiance durant
ces dernières heures nous ramène à la
conférence d'helsinki pour ne pas dire à
un processus qui s'appelle au processus
de corfou en 2009 où déjà à l'époque
dimitri medvedev président de la russie
avait appelé à ce qu'on traite des
questions de sécurité entre européens au
niveau de l'eau et ce en ne mélangeons
pas l'agenda politique de l'union
européenne et l'agenda sécuritaire
euro-atlantique de l'otan et breno rose
qui eux même diagnostic déjà pour
commencer un comment sont dans l'ordre
sur cette conférence de presse assez
clair dix minutes entre les trois des
gens certes elle sera suivie de
conversations privées mais ça dit
quelque chose cette conférence est
claire oui très certainement bien sûr
que si
si on a eu une très longue conférence
c'est un rencontre entre macro et
poutine c'est parce que c'était là où
l'enjeu se dérouler
aujourd'hui la conférence très courte
elle montre en fait que
or on prépare les réponses à à donner à
la russie et que
il n'y a pas pour le moment encore grand
chose à dire je dirais que l'essentiel
en fait c'est chez la position de
l'allemagne pourquoi parce que
l'allemagne est assez facilement accusé
d'être pro russe alors que à cause du
gazoduc nord stream biensur et aussi à
cause de beaucoup d'autres choses
puisque l'allemagne est une puissance
industrielle qui a beaucoup d'intérêt
développer des relations à l'est et en
particulier dans le résident encore en
particulier avec la russie est donc
toute l'attention qu'on a aujourd'hui
est largement
provoquée entre autres pour essayer
d'éloigner l'allemagne de la russie et
donc c'est important de voir que on a
envoyé si je veux dire l'union
européenne les européens auront plus ou
moins acceptée que si ce qu a prise en
macro qui représente l'europe à moscou
pendant que si je te dire le chancelier
allemand allait calmer les américains à
washington
juste devant washington ça veut dire
tout de même aimé dupuis tu es un nouvel
axe dans la négociation avant on avait
la russie face aux états unis un axe
américano européen désormais je suis
plus dubitatif que vous en premier
league et
en apportant un petit peu de modération
le président américain a été très
comminatoire vis-à-vis du chancellier
olaf scholz qui lui-même a botté en
touche le président américain je crois
en parle français paraphrasant ses mots
a dit nous trouverons un moyen de vous
empêcher que nord stream 2 ce qu'est ce
fonctionné le prêche en selle et
allemands à 10 ans on trouvera les
moyens
d'agir en concertation il n'a pas du
tout validé les propos du président
américain je répète que le chancelier
allemand et président du g7 le président
français et président du conseil de
l'union européenne il n'y a pas
forcément une adéquation parfaite sur
beaucoup de sujets mon collègue évoquée
lors asie la manière de traiter la
relation avec la chine l'allemagne est
le premier partenaire économique de la
chine sur le continent européen ce qui
n'est pas le cas de la france d'autant
plus que la france avec la décision de
décrire ce que la situation des
enseignants comme un génocide c'est un
petit peu éloigné singulièrement c'est
j'ose dire de pékin deuxième élément de
réflexion
le président polonais andrzej joue des
dida est un populiste je ne suis pas
certain que une forme d' escalade
l'arrangent d'autant plus qu'il est
voisin de la biélorussie comme de la
russie et que si il y avait une forme et
puis je rappelle que l'enclavé de
kaliningrad limitrophe de la pologne
également donc je suis pas certain non
plus que le président polonais
s'attendrait à une position militaire
s'attendrait un déplacement de troupes
américaines le président trump vous les
déplacez dix mille hommes en pologne on
en est pas à cette configuration donc je
crois qu'on est évidemment dans une
logique d désescalade je dirais pas
qu'il ya un front au ralenti par contre
il ya une volonté de la part de l'europe
de l'union européenne en tout cas des
pays européens de l'otan
de d'agir différemment vis-à-vis des
lumières poutine la chancellière angela
merkel le président macron en juin
dernier avait tenté un dernier baroud
d'honneur c'est j'ose dire en essayant
d'engager les 27 dans un dialogue avec
moscou 25 les 25 autres pays n'avait pas
validé cette approche force est de
constater que dans la situation critique
dans lequel nous nous trouvons
je crois qu'on va y arriver
progressivement en tout cas emmanuel
macron lui est plutôt optimiste
écoutez ce qu'il a dit à kiev un peu
plus tôt dans la journée
je crois pour ma part qu'il y a des
solutions concrètes
pratiques
qui nous permettront d'avancer nous
avons eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
ensemble j'ai eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
également avec le président poutine
comme je lé fais avec mes partenaires
européens et plusieurs de noëlle renaude
ronski c'est sûr que le président
français se montrent plutôt optimistes
c'est tout à son avantage
d'ailleurs y compris sur la scène
intérieure il n'empêche à moscou un
petit peu de tempérer cet enthousiasme
aujourd'hui on disant très bien il ya
une ouverture m'enfin pour le moment
les occidentaux n'ont pas vraiment
répondu à nos demandes de sécurité à nos
exigences entre guillemets ça il faut
aussi obtenir quoi on peut être soit
mais alors bien sûr que la russie a très
fermement rappelé ses exigences et il
faut évidemment prendre en compte que du
point de vue russe la russie a reculé
depuis trente ans et que là aujourd'hui
on a une espèce de niet pour parler plus
loin que sur ce plan là tu la russie est
ferme et risque de le rester donc ça
c'est très clair mais je dirais que
l'optimisme du président macron en
ukraine il est sans doute lié aussi au
fait que en dépit des
apparences le président ukrainien lui
même au cou un modéré ses exigences
depuis un certain temps il faut se
rappeler que la conversation qu'il a eue
avec le président pas et d'un récemment
ne s'est pas bien terminé puisque en
fait grosso modo à nice qui demandait
que les américains soient moins
menaçants
parce que l'attention aujourd'hui menace
directement l'ukraine n'ont pas
seulement d'une guerre parce que ça
apparemment il n'en est pas question
même si on en parle beaucoup mais c'est
la situation économique de l'ukraine qui
est catastrophique parce que
les tensions actuelles ont fait que la
monnaie ukrainienne s'était fourré et
que les grands oligarques que
l'ukrainien commencent à trouver que le
coût de cette crise
on sait que en ukraine ce sont les
oligarques qui gouverne et non pas les
institutions officielles d'ailleurs je
pense que dans la conférence de presse
du président macro il ya eu une petite
allusion à cela lorsqu'il a parlé de la
démocratisation d'ukraine il faut aussi
rappeler que quand il était à moscou
poutine lui avait mentionné quelques cas
des droits de l'homme violés en ukraine
donc tout cela évidemment a sans doute
fait que le prix ions maquereau a
rappelé à ses les skis que la l'ukraine
avancée certes selon lui mais peut-être
pas exactement au rythme voulu et en
même temps l'ukraine a absolument besoin
de paix pour pouvoir restaurer son
économie qui est en mauvaise posture
si l'ukraine elle même commencé un peu
se retirer de la stratégie de la tension
finalement il ne reste que les états
unis pourraient être très ferme à
l'égard de la russie ce qui fait quand
même assez peu en dépit du fait que
c'est évidemment la première puissance
mondiale mais ce n'est plus la puissance
unipolaire qu'on a connu il ya une
trentaine d'années
je voudrais compléter ce qu'a dit mon
collègue il a été d'ailleurs assez drôle
d'entendre le vote président vladimir
poutine offrir l'asile politique aux
deux anciens président loukachenko et
prochain qu en évoquant la question des
droits de l'homme comme ça a été
justement mentionné c'est d'ailleurs le
présent macro qui lui même a parlé de
démocratisation et puis il faut avoir
aussi à l'esprit que le président
volunteers est né ce qui a une majorité
un peu fragile à la rada et que
évidemment il a besoin aussi
donner l'impression qu'il est dans la
désescalade
la radicalisation est une vue que nous
aimerions avoir sur l'ukraine mais
l'ukraine ce ne se résume pas qu'à kiev
il ya des régions qui ont plus ou moins
des approches différentes de la entre la
périphérie est la capitale et puis après
il ya un autre élément effectivement à
dimension économique est déterminante
parce que les principaux acteurs ces
dernières années dans les
investissements les plus structurants
pour l'ukraine dans l'économie numérique
dans le spatial c'est ni les pays d'une
européenne et la russie mais la chine et
donc d'une certaine façon tout on a
intérêt à ce que n'avait pas versé
désescalade la russie le président
zelensky l'union européenne évidemment
les bailleurs de fonds qui sont plutôt
orientaux dernier point c'était j'ai
écouté les trois conférences de presse
donc celle à moscou et celle à kiev et
celle donc en pologne afin oui à berlin
pardon avec le président polonais j'ai
effectivement constaté que le président
zielinski lui-même se trouve dans une
dans la quadrature du cercle alors qu'il
ya quelques heures il réfuté ce que
contenait le protocole de minsk or tout
le monde veut le président poutine l'a
dit le président macron l'a redit trois
fois que l'on soit dans cette logique
des négociations le président des
risques est né ce qui risque d'avoir
beaucoup à convaincre à kiev et par
rapport à cette question est pourtant
bruno trotsky assez le modef 1 avant de
se rendre à moscou et emmanuel macron a
rappelé qu' une grande partie de la
solution et balle était justement entre
les mains du président zine ski tout à
fait ce que je peux manigod très léger
soeur est tout à fait juste
effectivement gêner ce qui joue un rôle
créé en même temps il n'a pas la force
nécessaire pour pouvoir imposer sans
négocier fortement sa politique tant sur
le plan international que sur le plan
intérieur donc il est dans une position
extrêmement fragile et en même temps
c'est finalement lui qui
est au centre de l'attention et donc
effectivement
son évolution est intéressante alors on
voit évidemment en ukraine des forces
d'opposition pu nationaliste essayer de
faire monter la pression mais
la menace qui est à nouveau maille dame
que cette opposition essaie de faire
d'eux de montrer ensemble à fait
irréaliste dans la mesure où l'ukraine
pour lui parce que j'étais très fatigué
merci mon adresse qui merci emmanuel
dupuis d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
décryptage ce soir merci à vous
emmanuel macron il velimir poutine qui
aurait également profité de cette
rencontre à moscou pour échanger sur un
tout autre dossier celui du nucléaire
iranien et négociations sur ce dossier
ont d'ailleurs repris aujourd'hui à
vienne en autriche là où siège l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
pour les états unis ce huitième ronde de
pourparlers avec téhéran est décisif on
retrouve notre correspondant washington
thomas bonnet bonsoir thomas les
américains qui ne participent pas
directement aux discussions dans la
capitale autrichienne mais qui semble en
attendre beaucoup
oui on suit ça de très près ici à
washington pour preuve en fin de semaine
dernière les etats-unis ont annoncé la
levée de certaines sanctions contre
l'iran pour permettre distillats des
pays de collaborer avec téhéran sur des
projets de nucléaire civil la diplomatie
américaine a dit que cela ne bénéficie
pas directement à l'iran mais que cela
permet d'avancer sur des disques une
discussion technique qui se déroule à
vienne ce qui nous a donné une nouvelle
passe d'armes entre le porte parole de
la diplomatie américaine ed price et un
journaliste deux épis mattely les deux
hommes s'étaient déjà un petit peu
accroché la semaine dernière sur le
dossier ukrainien et bien cette fois le
porte-parole de la diplomatie dit que
c'est une mesure qui vise donc à la non
prolifération qui est donc l'objectif
américain sur le dossier iranien c'est
une version quelque peu contestée par ce
journaliste qui voulait visiblement
poussé net price a affirmé qu'il
s'agissait d'une concession en faveur de
téhéran alors les officiels américains
affirment avec un accord est en vue mais
que les choses doivent aller très vite
on parle ici d'un délai de quelques
semaines seulement il ya donc urgence
pour ce qui concerne elle les dirigeants
américains notez également que joe biden
s'est entretenu ce dimanche avec le
premier ministre israélien israël qui on
le sait ne voit pas d'un très bon oeil
les termes qui se profile dans le cadre
d'un nouvel accord sur le nucléaire
iranien et joe biden qui a redit son
attachement à la sécurité israélienne il
a même accepté une invitation pour un
voyage dans le pays qui devrait avoir
lieu cette année merci thomas bonnin en
direct de washington et pour approfondir
sur ces négociations
nous accueillons sur se paie tôt thierry
coville chercheur à l'iris spécialiste
de l'iran bonsoir thierry coville merci
d'être avec nous alors avec cette
reprise des pourparlers on viens de
l'entendre sur le nucléaire iranien
l'objectif affiché par l'ensemble des
protagonistes est d'aller vite de
conclure un accord au plus vite des ja
est ce que ça vous semble réalisable
on va voir faut rester prudent dans ce
genre d'affaires mais disons c'est vrai
qu'on a pas mal de déclarations de
signes positifs surtout du côté iranien
et du côté américain donc il ya un
climat d'optimisme qui n'existait pas
déjà il ya même quelques semaines
pourquoi est ce si au jour soudainement
de conclure un accord pour notamment les
états unis il faut se méfier si vous
avez des fois on nous dit que ça
n'avance pas des fois que ça c'est
urgent et cetera ce qui est important
c'est que l'on soit plus optimiste
l'objectif de ces discussions c'est
comme que les états unis reviennent dans
la corde
2 juillet 2015
en tout cas ce qui semble se dégager ce
qu'on voit pas trop d'alternatives à
cette option donc bon et puis ce qui est
important c'est que ce soit un accord
solide surtout du côté iranien que du
côté gardien c'est important qu'on leur
joue pas ce qu'on leur a joué avec trump
c'est à dire qu'on disait tony signe en
accords en 2015 et en ressorte en 2018
donc c'est important que ce soit un
accord on va dire qu'il reste stable ce
sera le même accord définit dans les
mêmes termes oui tout à fait c'est ça
c'était au début c'était une discussion
entre les iraniens et américains parce
que les américains dit oui on veut bien
négocier mais ont négocié un nouvel
accord
votre politique régionale est votre
premier balistique les iraniens dit non
non vous êtes sortie de l'accord en mai
2018 ce qui vaut ce qu'il faut négocier
en fait elle mais y'a même pas à
négocier vous revenez dans cet accord
effectivement et derrière il ya la levée
des sanctions américaines et également
le fait que les dires en reviennent dans
l'accord de 2015 alors c'est vrai
qu'entre temps on l'a souvent commenté
téhéran a avancé sur son programme
nucléaire à ce que ça ce n'est pas de
nature justement à coincer est ce
compatible avec cet accord alors pour
revenir dans les étapes 1 trump sort de
l'accord mais 2018 l'iran respecté
l'accord à la lettre ce qui me demandent
par exemple les 23 10 10 rapport de
l'agencé internationale d'énergie mais
qui montre et clients respecter l'accord
pendant un an l'iran à respecter
l'accord et a demandé aux européens
qu'est ce que vous faites nous on veut
rester dans cet accord était important
pour nous que si vous faites pour lutter
contre les sanctions américaines voyant
que les européens ne faisait rien
l'iran considère pour changer de rapport
ce que c'était il ya une crise quand
même crise économique et sociale
3 l'iran n'a jamais vu ça depuis la
révolution donc pour changer le rapport
de force effectivement ils sont sortis
progressivement de l'accord de 2015 on
veut dire que c'était une question pour
eux de changer le rapport de force alors
effectivement maintenant il arrive il ya
un taux d'enrichissement d'uranium 60%
alors que pour la corse et de 3,7 pour
cent alors en tout cas joe biden lui non
j'avais fait mystère pendant sa campagne
il avait promis de réintégrer l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien boudé par
donald trump thomas bonnet vous êtes
toujours avec nous comment justement est
perçue cette promesse aux etats-unis du
président américain
est bien en tout cas c'est une promesse
très importante pour joe biden qui
compte bien l'honorer c'est une façon
pour lui aussi de rompre avec la
diplomatie donald trump on sait que le
départ de cet accord en 2018 avait
participé à la détérioration des
relations entre les états unis et les
alliés européens alors joe biden se dit
prêt à aller jusqu'au bout pour un
nouvel accord mais on sait que d'un
point de vue de politique intérieure ah
ça s'annonce assez compliqué il faut
rappeler qu'aucun républicain n'avait
voté en faveur de cet accord en 2015
sous la présidence de barack obama et
ces dernières heures une lettre de 33
sénateur républicain a été adressée à
joe biden trente trois sénateurs
républicains emmené par tête cruz qui
demandent donc à joe biden que l'accord
soit d'abord ratifier par le congrès
avant qu'il n'entre en application on
sait qu'ils avaient déjà tenté de bloqué
cet accord en 2015 mais que le démocrate
était finalement parvenu à le ratifier
alors cette fois la marge de manoeuvre
est plus faible pour joe biden surtout à
l' approche des élections de mi-mandat
qui vont se dérouler à l'automne
prochain ici aux etats unis les
républicains pourraient bien retrouver
une majorité au congrès c'est donc un
sujet qui s'invite déjà dans la campagne
y compris dans la campagne
présidentielle de 2024 puisque dans la
même lettre peut-être cruz affirme qu'en
cas de victoire en 2024 les républicains
reviendrait sur un quelconque accord
conquis avec les avec l'iran des menaces
qui fragilise quelque peu la position de
joe biden parce qu'on sait que téhéran
s'inquiètent justement de la versatilité
de la diplomatie américaine merci thomas
bonne et c'est intéressant ce que nous
dit taux d'abonnées parce que
effectivement on parlait de confiance
tout à l'heure dans les négociations sur
la crise du crédit yens là la confiance
elle est difficilement réalisable avec
cette versatilité comme nous l'a
expliqué notre correspondant oui on va
dire
c'est un vrai traumatisme en iran pour
le reste les médias parce qu'ils
croyaient vraiment pas que les ethnies
ray jusque là s'il respectait
parfaitement d'accord donc cette sortie
de l'accord effectivement alors déjà il
ya une méfiance vis-à-vis des etats-unis
du côté des radicaux qui sont au pouvoir
en iran on va dire il ya une haine des
états unis alors vous imaginez avec ses
sorties de la coque et qui dieu du point
de vue iranien je pense du point de vue
même du droit international est
complètement illégal donc effectivement
il ya un gros problème de de confiance
et c'est pour ça que les iraniens
demandent des garanties sur le fait que
si les ethnies reviendra corps il n'en
ressortent pas alors effectivement vous
venez plus en avoir parce qu'on a vu il
ya une vraie division sein des
démocrates et des républicains ça pose
problème est question je pense du côté
iranien alors ils le disent dans les
discussions les déclarations qui font
ils ont bien compris que effectivement
sous le mandat de biden les états unis 6
0 vienne est récurrent dans l'accord ils
ont bien compris que effectivement s'il
ya un nouveau président notamment
républicain là il y aura des risques
mais d'un autre côté c'est pas aussi
simple que ça parce que si les états
unis revient dans l'accord l'iran le
respecte de nouveau parfaitement
sortir de nouveau de l'accord alors là
effectivement rappelons quand même
l'iran est à 60% d'enrichissement
l'uranium sur sortie de l'accord là il
ya des durs en errant qui croient pas à
l'accord qu'ils disent et un accord pour
affaiblir les rangs il propose de sortir
du traité de non-prolifération donc le
président républicain prendra un énorme
risque si déchiré nouveau l'accord en
tout cas au terran insisté de son côté
sur la priorité qui doit être la
suppression des sanctions à cette
fiction évidemment l'économie du pays
c'est évidemment un enjeu un levier
important la levée de ces sanctions
c'est tout simplement ce que demandent
les rangs depuis le début ils ont dit
écoutez vous revenez dans l'accord ce
qui est important pour nous c'est que
vous avez réimposer ces sanctions en
sortant de l'accord pourrait vous
enlevez de nouveau ces sanctions parce
que je vous dis non non c'est on emploie
souvent les moqueries dans l'actualité
de ça là on iran c'est une crise
économique profonde soyez une baisse en
dessous de 15 % du pib 2018 2019 une
crise sociale profonde chômage énorme on
commence à voir des immigrations
seulement des jeunes diplômés iranien
qui partent notamment en europe au
royaume uni etc donc c'est une crise
économique sociale et je pense en grande
partie causée par ces sanctions donc ce
que demande l'iran c'est le droit
international quelque part vous revenez
dans l'accord et vous enlevez le toutes
ces options vous avait réimposé merci
beaucoup t comme il d'avoir été avec
nous nous avoir apporté votre décryptage
merci à vous également thomas bonnet en
direct de washington
et les etats unis toujours avec cette
fois ci cette vente d'armes à taïwan un
contrat de 100 millions de dollars pour
la modernisation des missiles de l'état
insulaire medalliance pas au goût de
pékin les précisions de thibaut janin
entre les états unis et taïwan la
relation est au beau fixe quelques
heures après l'officialisation de
l'accord commercial taipei a exprimé ce
mardi sa gratitude à washington pour
avoir approuvé cette vente
il s'agit de la deuxième vente d'armes à
taiwan depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir du
président joe biden et la première cette
année cela reflète l'alliance solide
comme de la pierre entre taiwan et les
etats unis une entente renforcée pour
maintenir à niveau le système de défense
aérienne patriotes mais surtout un atout
de dissuasion alors que l'île est en
proie à des incursions d'avions de
combats chinois pékin qui revendique sa
souveraineté sur l'île n'a pas tardé à
réagir
la chine condamne vivement l'accord
commercial militaires conclus entre les
états unis et taiwan
l'inde et la chine s'y oppose fermement
et le condamne avec force les états unis
devraient respecter le principe d'une
seule chine et les dispositions des
trois communiqués conjoints
sino-américains annuler immédiatement le
plan de vente d'armes à taiwan
susmentionnés mettre fin aux ventes
d'armes à taiwan et aux liens militaires
entre les états unis et taiwan
la chine qui envisage de prendre des
mesures je cite légitime et énergique
pour défendre sa souveraineté et ses
intérêts en matière de sécurité sans
préciser lesquelles
cette vente d'armes pourrait venir saper
un peu plus les relations sino
américaines ce n'est pas la première
fois que les états unis passent un
contrat militaire dans cette région du
monde en fin d'année dernière washington
s'était déjà engagé à livrer des sous
marins nucléaires à l'australie une
alliance qui avait irrité la chine
décrivant une vente extrêmement
irresponsables
en amérique centrale à présent on
connaît la fiche du second tour de la
présidentielle un au costa rica un
ex-président et un ex-ministre
s'affronteront pour la magistrature
suprême et précision de julien albert
ils étaient 25 ce dimanche et ne sont
plus que 2 ce lundi procès maria
figueres et rodrigo chaves ont dominé le
premier tour de la présidentielle
costaricaine cros et maria figueres 67
ans ex président du pays au milieu des
années 1990 a survolé ce premier round
en recueillant près de 28% des voix l'ex
chef d'état qui avait fait de la lutte
contre le chômage et de la pauvreté
touchant plus d'un habitant sur cinq une
de ses priorités est très fier de ce
résultat
extraordinaire
le résultat a été extraordinaire
nous sommes un pas du début du sauvetage
et de la transformation du costa rica
nous avons remporté ce premier tour avec
une solide avance cela nous donne aussi
une énorme responsabilité alors demain
nous continuerons le travail acharné
pour la victoire finale le 3 avril
[Musique]
elle plante iman thèse bien
en face rodrigo chaves 60 ans ex
ministre de l'économie a également comme
objectif de sortir le costa rica de la
situation de pauvreté dans laquelle est
jeté le pays à l'heure de ce scrutin
celui qui a passé 27 ans à la banque
mondiale estime avoir l'expérience et le
courage nécessaires pour relever le défi
avec 17% des suffrages recueillis au
premier tour il apparaît comme un
sérieux adversaire pour re c'est maria
fig est ce un ancien président face à un
ex ministre pour une place de chef
d'état verdict le 3 avril prochain à
l'occasion du second tour
dans le reste de l'actualité ces
nouvelles révélations sujet du logiciel
israélien d'espionnage pegasus après
avoir été utilisée contre des
journalistes hommes politiques ou encore
chefs d'entreprise à l'international l'
affaire rebondit désormais au sein même
de l'état hébreu adrien faut
c'est un nouveau scandale qui vient
entacher le renseignement israéliens
selon un quotidien économique du pays de
nombreuses personnalités publiques ont
été espionnés par la police israélienne
sans autorisation judiciaire
le logiciel utilisé pegasus propriété de
haine et ce au groupe israélien de
cybersécurité parmi les personnalités
espionnées des journalistes cabinets
ministériels mais aussi à venir
netanyahu un des fils de l'ancien
premier ministre benyamin nétanyahou et
l'actuel chef du gouvernement naftali
bennett qui condamne fermement le mode
opératoire
c'est un triste jour une journée noire
pour l'état d'israël sans faire
référence à mon cas personnel je pense
que cette affaire concerne tous les
citoyens du pays que vous soyez de
droite de gauche tous les citoyens sans
exception sont visés quelque chose
d'inconcevable s'est produit ici autant
l'abattre
bignanais par châtel pigasos
concernant la sphère pegasus les
informations semble décrire une
situation très sérieuse et inadmissible
dans une démocratie
pegasus et d'autres outils similaires
sont importants dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et la grande criminalité
mais ils ne sont pas destinés à être
utilisés contre le public israélien nous
veillerons à ce que les enquêtes soient
transparentes approfondie et rapide car
nous méritons tous des réponses que ce
soit les citoyens de l'état d'israël les
ministres du gouvernement où tous les
établissements concernés l'annoncera
même xala et quand la marotte medio choo
votre illégales les modalités
d'espionnage de la police israélienne se
seraient multipliées ces derniers mois
toujours selon le quotidien calcalist
est plus qu'une enquête interne pour cet
avocat spécialisé dans le droit
informatique les responsables doivent
être traduits en justice
selon moi cela doit se terminer par un
procès un procès pénal et pas seulement
une enquête interne car si ces
allégations sont exactes nous sommes
confrontés à des faits à la limite de
l'espionnage et de la trahison et pas
seulement des cas qui devrait être réglé
de manière administrative
la collecte de données étaient immenses
sans précédent et illégales surtout avec
la création d'une base de données qui
pourrait nuire à n'importe qui et si
quelqu'un au sommet de la hiérarchie
était au courant il doit également être
poursuivi
face à cette menace démocratique le
président isaac herzog et les autorités
israéliennes promettent une réponse
forte créateur de pegasus le groupe nse
rejette de son côté toute implication
dans le fonctionnement du système une
fois vendues à des clients
gouvernementaux
un nouveau rapport sur la crise
climatique très alarmant il pointe les
manquements de grandes entreprises des
firmes qui sont nombreuses à s'être
engagés comme les gouvernements à des
objectif de neutralité carbone dans les
décennies à venir et selon les travaux
d'un groupe de réflexion allemand en
partenariat avec une ong ces annonces ne
sont que de la poudre aux yeux pour la
plupart
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
retour en france où les convois de la
liberté doivent prendre le départ demain
de dans plusieurs villes certains
groupes sur les réseaux sociaux cumule
déjà plus de deux cent soixante mille
membres de nombreux opposants aux
restrictions sanitaires antico vie
doivent converger à paris avant d'aller
à bruxelles un mouvement de protestation
inspirés des manifestations géantes qui
ont lieu au canada et qui impacte
également la grande bretagne ou encore
la nouvelle zélande et coûteux
il s'agit de la liberté de choix et
d'être vous savez de notre droit à
disposer de notre propre corps plutôt
que de se faire dicter son usage je suis
pro vaccin le vaccin est une très bonne
chose mais nous devrions pouvoir décider
si nous voulons la voir ou non je suis
ici aujourd'hui pour protester contre
les mesures car j'ai perdu mon emploi à
cause d'elle et j'ai adoré ce travail
oui actuellement j'essaie de trouver un
travail ce qui est vraiment vraiment
difficile en ce moment pour moi mais je
ne pense pas que les gens sont au
courant des sacrifices que nous avons
faits je sais bien que c'est mon choix
de ne pas me faire vacciner mais cela
engendrait plein de complications sur ma
famille mais aussi l'abandon de certains
amis le sentiment d'isolement même des
conséquences psychologiques comme vous
savez l'envi de suicide et ça c'est
vraiment fou et au canada où le
mouvement a débuté la situation est
toujours aussi tendue dimanche le maire
de la capitale ottawa a déclaré l'état
d'urgence hier c'est le chef de la
police qui a haussé le ton maxime abers
nous avons compté arrestation et
inculpation une personne qui ont
enfreint la loi directement ou
indirectement en ce qui concerne cette
manifestation
un tonnerre de klaxons une circulation
paralysée dans les grandes artères des
commerces fermés et des écoles
inaccessible la capitale canadienne a
toutes les apparences d'une ville en
état de siège les camionneurs du convoi
de la liberté bloque toujours le
centre-ville d'ottawa et la mairie a
déclaré l'état d'urgence face à cette
vague de contestation sans précédent
face au ras-le-bol des habitants peter
slowly a pris la parole ce lundi le chef
de la police d'ottawa a annoncé des
arrestations par dizaines et la saisie
de milliers de litres de carburant nous
nous concentrons sur le carburant nous
poursuivons tous les véhicules les
moyens de transport y compris les
chevaux les personnes transportant des
jerrycans nous procédons à des
arrestations et à des saisies et nous
interdisons l'approvisionnement en
carburant des manifestations nous avons
essayé de mettre fin à ce mouvement par
la négociation comme nous le faisons
toujours lorsque cela a échoué nous
sommes passés à une opération d'ordre
public appelé à l'aide par le maire de
la ville justin trudeau a rappelé le
droit des canadiens à manifester mais le
premier ministre reste ferme sur le
réseau social twitter il promet de
fournir les ressources nécessaires pour
mettre fin au blocage
les canadiens ont le droit de manifester
de se poser au gouvernement et de faire
entendre leur voix on va toujours
protéger ce droit mais soyons clairs ils
n'ont pas le droit de faire obstruction
à l'économie la démocratie ou au
quotidien de nos concitoyens c'est assez
depuis janvier les troqueurs protestent
contre les restrictions sanitaires mises
en place dans tout le pays ils dénoncent
une mesure en particulier l'obligation
vaccinale pour franchir la frontière
avec les états unis est rentré dans leur
propre pays même s'ils gagnent nous
partirons pas nous voulons la fin de la
vaccination obligatoire le retour de la
liberté
deux dernières années nous ont été volés
je suis ici pour mes enfants je ne
partirai pas désolé ils peuvent
poursuivre en justice attaquer j'espère
que le peuple canadien il soutiendra et
perd à l'amande
selon les sondages seulement un canadien
sur trois soutiendrait la fronde des
routiers leur mouvement a pourtant reçu
un soutien massif sur internet
réunissant jusqu'à 10 millions de
dollars via une plateforme de
financement participatif qui a depuis
geler les fonds malgré la grogne des
riverains ces derniers drapeau canadien
en main ne semble pas prêt à renoncer à
ce combat de poids l'eau
et on en parlait il ya quelques instants
négociations sur le nucléaire iranien
tournée diplomatique dans le dossier
ukrainien
emmanuel macron endosser derniers temps
le costume d'un chef d'état à
l'international une tribune médiatique
exceptionnelle pour le président
français c'est l'édito d'alexis paulin
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis alors pour un président
en a un qui comptent sans doute on va
pas être voilà à faire des plans sur la
comète mais enfin on va imaginer qu'ils
qu'il est un petit peu envie de briguer
un second mandat emmanuel macron faut
dire que cette séquence internationale
est un petit peu du du pain bénit n'est
ce pas ah ben c'est sûr que là pour
emmanuel macron ça lui permet d'user de
sa stature présidentielle jusqu'au bout
d'éviter d'enjamber la campagne
électorale emmanuel macron c'est quand
même le roi de la fuite en avant le roi
de leskiw à la fois il ne défend pas son
bilan il se projette dans l'avenir il se
pose aussi en pacificateur celui qui va
apporter la solution en ukraine comme si
c'était que lui ce serait merveilleux et
qui va peut-être même vaincre le coc
vide avec ces mesures formidable comme
le pass vaccinale donc il est en train
d'écrire un une séquence de
communication pour lancer sa campagne
sur les bases de macron le sauveur en
avait on a tous eu avec emmanuel macron
depuis cinq ans il nous manquait le
sauveur le voilà qui a ri qui va sortir
de son avion retour de berlin pour aller
en plus récupérer les turbines à general
electric alors qu'il avait oeuvré bien
sûr pour vendre ses turbines à la lente
reprise américaine donc c'est vraiment
de la communication du marketing
politique encore et toujours r moyens
pour emmanuel macron d'éviter le débat
d'éviter d'entrer en campagne
le sauveur c'est parfois ce qu'on
pouvait presque lire dans les médias
français après sa rencontre hier avec
vladimir poutine de la part des
journalistes dont certains avaient la
chance d'ailleurs de l'avoir accompagné
dans l'avion présidentiel c'est
d'ailleurs la tradition le
fonctionnement des voyages de presse on
est dans l'avion avec le président et
ont fait la tournée avec lui on a droit
à une petite phrase en off qui sont
ensuite reprises dans la presse
absolument alors il ya deux façons de
faire soyez un avion pour la presse sur
les long courriers soit on est dans
l'avion présidentiel
et effectivement on peut poser des
questions le président vient vous voir
sortez de ces quartiers présidentielle
pour rabab donner les bonnes petites
phrases pour montrer qu'il est proche
des médias qu'il est aussi aux commandes
de tout est ici la géographie qu'on est
là quasiment dans de la propagande
d'état évidemment on va avoir droit aux
reportages emmanuel macron offrons à la
campagne de l'est d'emmanuel macron la
campagne de russie enfin on aura tous à
peu près sur ce passage en ukraine et en
russie d' emmanuel macron c'est vrai que
la presse présidentielle c'est une
institution c'est aussi une façon bien
de d'assurer que la parole
présidentielle et reprise telle quelle
que aussi lors des conférences de presse
certaines questions sont posées comme
sur le mali où d'autres pour s'assurer
que on peut faire passer des messages à
l'autre qui nous reçoit lors des voyages
présidentiels
c'est clairement depuis quelques jours
quand je dis macro le sauveur moi je le
dis évidemment avec ironie mais pour
beaucoup de confrères non ils le disent
vraiment sincèrement heureux de voir que
le président français est si formidable
et allant même jusqu à en rajouter c'est
vrai que quand on est bien traité
lorsqu'on est la presse présidentielle
puisqu'on a droit à quelques égards
alors justement parmi les petites
questions y en a forcément eu sur la
candidature dans cet avion présidentiel
il va falloir ils sont gc ca
et c'est tant que emmanuel macron disent
qu'il est candidat parce que les pauvres
militants de la république en marche qui
commence à faire campagne tous ceux qui
ont déjà offert leurs parrainages à
emmanuel macron seront ils au feu l'un
d'une non candidature
non évidemment c'est une question de
timing alors certains proches disent
entre le 10 et le 20 février bon alors
on y arrive mais il va falloir choisir
le bon timing le bon timing c'est
évidemment s'assurer que la vague ou
micron est derrière s'assurer aussi que
sur l'ukraine il n'y aura pas un
revirement de situation de joe biden on
l'a vu dans la crise des sous-marins les
américains peuvent tout à fait trahir et
modèles maquereau ou bien décider de
sourire par devant et d'attaqués par
derrière donc il faut s'assurer pour lui
que son message et son sa promotion
puisqu'il est en promotion il n'est pas
encore en campagne peuvent fonctionner
et non pas retombée comme un soufflé si
jamais tout repartait dans le rouge et
si jamais il était en échec sur ces deux
thématiques donc voilà c'est clairement
maintenant le temps pour le mcs ronde
d'entrée dans la campagne mais il va
falloir qu'il accepte de débattre avec
tout le monde et surtout de défendre un
bilan calamiteux aujourd'hui sortent les
chiffres de la balle du commerce
extérieur un déficit de 84 milliards
d'euros
je ne vois pas comment on peut défendre
un bilan de ce type là avec la dette qui
explose avec évidemment les dépenses
publiques aussi qu'ils sont dans le
rouge ça va être très compliqué même
s'il continue d'aller toujours dans la
fuite en avant de faire des chèques et
de dire que c'est le sauveur est le
meilleur président du monde reste à voir
merci avec six poulains pour votre édito
ce soir est resté avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parleront d'une
nouvelle sortie médiatique d'eric
zemmour selon lui les hlm sont des
terres d'islamisation du pays et propos
stigmatisants et jugé comme mensonge et
par l'union sociale pour l'habitat qui
décide de porter plainte contre le
candidat à la présidentielle alors
énième provocation ou un véritable conte
ce pape dans les quartiers on en parle
[Musique]
vous avez lancé des appels à la
mobilisation notamment pour pour bloquer
des ponts mais vous avez été arrêtés
qu'est ce qui s'est passé j'ai été
arrêté pour complot incitations d'un
acte criminel et terroriste
cette fois la première fois qu'au québec
un bon arrêt des blagues et mais dans
les mesures que nous sommes en ce moment
sanitaire est très autoritaire du
gouvernement
je crois qu'ils ont voulu démontrer
qu'ils avaient la force d'autorité il ya
une volonté aussi peut-être de
discréditer tous tous ces mouvements
anti mesures sanitaires ont sas abraham
a mis à l'écart ici au québec et au
canada
l'intéressé d'avoir un dépôt public
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux et
d'aider des gens ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts ni sur la bbc une solide et
hopitalisé il était nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pensais que tout le monde connaissait
déjà kim philby le plus fameux des
espions britanniques après james bond
rappelez-nous pourquoi il s'est tourné
vers le communisme il pensait que la
gauche s'étaient vendus il se disait la
démocratie la démocratie sociale ne fait
pas le travail et il a vu l'avènement
d'hitler en allemagne donc il regardait
l'union soviétique comme un bastion anti
fasciste
l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la
force de son engagement idéologique
l'autre chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier
à son sujet et qu'il avait des capacités
extraordinaires pour la tromperie
c'était un menteur tout à fait brillant
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il ya quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coups politiques n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité les ide et
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
il y a trente ans l'union soviétique
s'est effondré comment avez vous perçu
ces événements à l'époque j'étais parmi
les partisans de la démocratie la
rédaction du journal russia se trouvait
à la maison blanche nous avons passé
deux nuits inoubliables à la rédaction à
la maison blanche on était au centre de
presse du ministère des affaires
étrangères lors de la célèbre conférence
de presse du comité d'état pour l'état
d'urgence j'ai bien sûr changé plusieurs
fois d'opinion sur ces événements comme
tout le monde s'en doute mais à ce
moment là il y avait bien sûr une sorte
d'euphorie démocratique sans
enthousiasme il est probablement si
seulement j'avais pu imaginer à l'époque
en août 91 à quoi aboutir et ces
événements pour que c'est encore un
stade chaud non se terminerait cet
enthousiasme joyeux dans la lutte contre
le monopole du parti communiste et la
censure en apprenant coppens mais
personne ne pensait que cela aboutirait
à l'effondrement d'un grand pays
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire une nouvelle sortie médiatique
d'eric zemmour très critiquée selon lui
les hlm sont des terres d'islamisation
du pays des propos stigmatisants jugé
comme mensonge et par l'union sociale
pour l'habitat qui décide de porter
plainte contre le candidat à la
présidentielle une énième provocation ou
un véritable constat dans les quartiers
en france islamisation les villes en
font l ac on attend vos réactions sur le
conte télégramme verte et france
l'union sociale pour l'habitat a donc
décidé de porter plainte contre eric
zemmour en cause une nouvelle sortie
médiatique stigmatisant les hlm pour en
parler on retrouve notre reporter lucas
léger à proximité du qg de campagne du
candidat de reconquête bonsoir le cas à
l'origine de la colère donc les propos
d'eric zemmour qualifiant les logements
sociaux de terre d'islamisation du pays
oui absolument et c'est une sortie qui a
fait beaucoup réagir c'est dans la
droite ligne de ce que fait avec zemmour
depuis le début de la présidentielle
c'est à dire ne pas prendre de pincettes
sur les sujets qui lui tiennent à coeur
la semaine dernière devant le syndicat
de police alliance il avait déjà évoqué
les hlm il avait déclaré que les parents
de délinquants mineurs qui vivent dans
des hlm seront expulsés s'il s'ils
habitent cette fois il n'a pas hésité
lors d'un entretien à france inter à
s'en prendre aux hlm qui selon lui qu
mena grand nombre des problèmes qu'il
dénonce je vous propose d'écouter ce
qu'il a dit
tout le monde sait aujourd'hui tous les
français savent aujourd'hui sauf
peut-être dans ce studio est dans le
bureau de monsieur qui dirige l'abbé
pierre que les hlm sont des terres
d'islamisation du pays tout le monde
sait aujourd'hui surtout les pauvres
gens et les braves gens qui sont restés
qui n'ont pas pu fuir ces hlm devenus
des entre à kebab et à femmes voilées
sans compter les trafics de drogue et
les réactions ne se sont pas fait
attendre l'union sociale pour l'habitat
qui est dirigé par l'ancien ministre
emmanuelle cosse a annoncé qu'il portait
plainte contre le candidat à
l'organisation estime que les 11 lyon
deux personnes qui vivent dans les hlm
et les 80000 personnes qui travaillent
dans le secteur des hlm sont insultés
par ses propos je vous propose d'écouter
ce qu'ils ont écrit
des propos particulièrement stigmatisant
et mensongers à l'égard des organismes
hlm et de leurs occupants avec lesquels
l'union sociale pour l'habitat est en
totale opposition depuis 150 ans les
organismes hlm ont accueilli dans le
parc social des populations françaises
ou étrangères sans discrimination
concourant à faire de la france en
logeant la france telle qu'elle est une
terre d'accueil et d'intégration est le
cas l'immigration thème évidemment
favoris d'eric zemmour qui signent et
persistent aujourd'hui encore
absolument il a publié deux tweets dans
la journée notamment avec un tract qui
rappelle qu'il veut supprimer la loi sru
qui impose une part de logements sociaux
dans les villes qui rappelle aussi bien
sûr qu'il veut supprimer l'immigration
est qu'il veut la priorité aux français
dans le logement social il a aussi
publié une synthèse de son programme sur
la sécurité et qui préconise l'expulsion
automatique des trafiquants et leurs
familles des logements sociaux merci de
cas légers en direct
du qg de campagne en tout cas à
proximité du qg de campagne d'eric
zemmour alors les propos du candidat
énième provocation ou véritable constat
dans les quartiers l'islamisation les
villans font-elles c'est pour lutter
contre la radicalisation on attend vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme
berthet france et place à notre débat
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler jean marie
vilain mer les centristes de viry
châtillon qui a été tant que visé par
les propos d'eric zemmour à vos côtés
tommaso votre ce qui porte parole du
collectif droite pour la france et
soutien du candidat zemmour bonsoir à
tous les deux merci d'être là donc
regroupé trappe viry-châtillon votre
ville et eghezée moore compare toutes
les banlieues l'afghanistan c'est à dire
des zones de guerre vous dites que vous
allez porter plainte contre le candidat
du parti à la reconquête
vous êtes en colère jean marie ville a
expliqué nous je suis surtout en colère
parce que je pense à toutes ces
personnes qui qui se lèvent de tous les
matins toutes ces personnes qui
travaillent pour justement une
intégration et pour le vivre ensemble à
viry-châtillon les professeurs les
associations les élus aussi parce que de
temps en temps on fait un petit peu
quelque chose on n'est pas complètement
inutiles on se on se bat pas juste pour
avoir des places on se bat aussi parce
que on est attaché un autre moi je suis
très attaché à ma commune et quand je
quand j'entends des mots pareils qui
stigmatisent d'une manière radicale
justement la commune de viry châtillon
vial châtillon c'est bien autre chose
que ça les châtillons c'est le siège
d'alpine ce n'est ceux qui développent
le moteur des formule 1 dès réception
c'est les lacs qui sont les plus beaux
de l'île de france et c'est très modeste
ce que je dis et puis viry-châtillon
c'est un champion du monde d'athlétisme
c'est ladji doucouré j'ai tout ça ccsa
viry châtillon et quand je vois que tous
les matins on allume cette petite flamme
pour justement permettre aux habitants
de viry-châtillon d'être le mieux
possible que j'entends qu'on crache
ainsi au visage de 31 mille habitants
sans même connaître la ville parce que
je doute en tout cas je ne l'ignorent
mais j'ai jamais vu eric zemmour ici
donc moi je suis pro en guerre je veux
dire eric zemmour il est candidat il a
toute légitimité la lettre s'il obtient
ces signatures et c'est la démocratie
celle avantages de notre pays pour
autant on peut attendre quand même autre
chose d'un président de la république
que de balancer des petites phrases qui
ruine quand même un travail important
pas que le mien celui des associations
comme je disais des professeurs de tous
ceux qui aiment notre ville
thomas votre camp vous attendez
suivi l'un s'exprimait ainsi vous vous
dites votre candidat ce qui n'est pas
allé un petit peu trop loin cela il ya
deux choses quand j'ai le peuple et
compris quel titre ou courtiers plainte
parce que je sais pas si c'est vous ou
la fédération des offices hlm
association de deux truites deux choses
différentes d'accord la vie ne fait pas
plainte la ville de sicile la ville
désire et châtillon va d'abord parce que
ça doit passer en conseil municipal
parce que c'est pas moi qui ai qui
suivent atteint directement c'est la
ville de viry châtillon et c'est l'image
de la ville de viry châtillon donc nous
allons passer en conseil municipal une
délibération
donc ça dépendra du vote de la
délibération c1 c'est un conseil
municipal souverain et si ce vote est
actée et bien la ville portera plainte
justement pour atteinte à son image et à
ça et surtout à l'image des habitants
parce que moi c'est les habitants qui me
d'accord mais ce que j'aime bien la
comprendre les chats les jeunes se sont
posés moi je pense que c'est vraiment je
suis désolé en plus on est on est
voisins territoriaux et a franchement
laid le travail que fait monsieur ville
à viry-châtillon vous aurez jamais vu
historiquement n'est rien un tweet de
critiques ou que ce soit parce que je
sais que c'est une ville qui l'a repris
et qui fait que les équipes font un
travail formidable tout la revanche en
revanche non mais en revanche je ne
comprends pas
que vous vous inscriviez dans un théâtre
c'est un théâtre politique à chaque fois
qu'ils rient zemmour dit quelque chose
de tout à fait normal et raisonnable on
crie à la diabolisation la stime il a
dit qu'il y avait beaucoup de musulmans
dans l'est qui cité hlm et donc moi je
souhaite bon courage aux associations
concernées sassi
l'islamisation il a déjà fait lyon c'est
l'afghanistan non666 dans les rangs
châtillon c'est l'afghanistan c'est le
mood et l'exil moi j'avais entendu sur
roubaix
pardonnez-moi thomas quant aux
communautés musulmanes on se retrouve
avec l'afghanistan et hlm sont des
terres d'islamisation voilà les propos
exacts d'eric zemmour d'accord parce que
sur la question de dire que dans les
quartiers hlm de banlieue parisienne et
d'autres grandes métropoles il ya une
communauté musulmane extrêmement
importante et majoritaire veut dire tout
le monde le sait se dope à des propos il
n'a parlé dix steaks hachés moi j'ai
entendu la chatte chacun l'interprète
non moi j'ai entendu non non il faut
apprendre le texte moi je pense que vous
devez alors le texte attendez le texte
n'ait été donnée avant moi je rebondis
ce qu'on nous a été donnée à
viry-châtillon c'est l'afghanistan il
n'a pas parlé de cité hlm de rien viry
châtillon moi c'est en gardant copavil
attendu suis attendu auparavant et les
personnes qu une goutte qui ont entendu
exactement que la première déclaration
attardé on va papa réclamait 6 6 mais
c'est important quand même moins on est
vieux on peut y venir après je peux
faire en deux temps bien sûr
que les associations qui porte plainte
c'est pas pour viry-châtillon c'est pour
avoir dit qu'il y avait une islamisation
dans la quartier hlm or il ya une
islamisation dans la quartier hlm
extrêmement visible à viry-châtillon ou
ailleurs ou à saint jean des voix avec
une majorité de population de femmes
voilées alors d'accord ils n'ont pas la
burqa et ça personne ne peut le nier
donc de toutes façons c'est un sujet
auquel on doit s'atteler de voir comment
est-ce qu'on gère notre politique
migratoire qui se retrouvent de façon
majoritaire dans des quartiers hlm à
paris théâtre vous parlez de théâtre est
donc
déjà dit et je veux être sûr que
maintenant mes jeux sur un argument très
précis si on dit si dire qu'il ya des
musulmans dans la quartier hlm c'est de
la stigmatisation c'est à dire que
quelqu'un musulmans c'est une médiation
c'est ce que disent les associations
c'est ce que disent les associations et
c'est parce qu'il a dit ce qu'il a dit
non non non je suis désolé
retrouver la france a précisé eric
zemmour tournée modèles gt en deux temps
donc je ne sais pas dessiner même si on
peut avancer du plan de
m'adonner moi j'ai enfin la phrase
remercie tout le monde sait aujourd'hui
tous les français savent aujourd'hui
sauf peut-être dans ce studio est dans
le bureau de monsieur qui dirige la
vespière que les hlm sont des terres
dynamisation du pays tout le monde sait
aujourd'hui surtout les pauvres et les
braves gens qui sont restés qui n'ont
pas su influencer hlm devenus des autres
à kebab et femmes voilées sans compter
les trafics de drogue voilà la phrase
exacte du candidat au sénat sur france
inter le 16 février dans la phrase de
monsieur darmanin je suis navré il parle
bien de roubaix viry-châtillon vitry et
tra comme étant l'afghanistan ça c'est
pas je ne parle pas des à 2h ll je parle
de cette phrase là et cette phrase qui
la tunisie et il ya eu une autre phrase
que j'ai dite est tout à fait sûr
viry-châtillon il a bien dit les
châtillons et l afghanistan c est ce qu
on peut je peux terminer mes deux temps
parce qu'on vous venez dire la même
chose si on avait deux mois j'ai pas
envie de parler de viry châtillon à la
fin donc sur la première phrase sur les
hlm comme territoire ou liane
islamisation importante tout le monde
sait que c'est vrai donc c'est là c'est
dans ce sujet là où je considère qu'il
ya un théâtre absolument pas possible
qu'ils évitent événement traiter le
sujet est traité le problème après sur
l'inclusion de viry-châtillon que je
connais effectivement les faire comparer
d'afghanistan c'est tout à fait excessif
et je trouve que c'est une maladresse
donc je ne sais pas comment il réagit je
peux et je me suis lâché d'accord si
c'est une maladresse dans ces cas là il
faut des excuses il faut des excuses
parce que je ne veux pas parler de vache
par genre parmi le voyez ce que j'essaie
de distinguer deux choses en descente
précédant les deux ça m'est arrivé de
nous tromper mais moi quand je me trompe
je suis capable de leur côté sur une
graine moi je pense reconnaître aussi
les riches châtillon pâtes ou moins que
vous entre ce qui se passe à roubaix où
pour le coup en termes religieux c'est
effectivement l'afghanistan à après
moins de parler quand on a des filles
est des magasins qui vendent des poupées
de filles et de son visage je pense que
vous serez re j'imagine que si vous avez
une demande d'ouverture avec cette
comptine du commerce au-dessus du degré
de progrès qu'on pouvait d'accord moi
j'essaye de diable est une maladresse
moi de vous couper mais justement un
puisqu il faut être prêt si on cherche
les phrase exacte roubaix roubaix
l'afghanistan à deux heures de paris à
20 minutes de chez vous c'est ce qu'il a
dit lors de son meeting lillois il a
fils fustigé l' islamisation de
deux-roues b alors que la réalisatrice 1
de ce reportage qu'on a vu évidemment et
sur m6 sur roubaix
avait précisé qu'il n'ya pas seulement
que ça qu'il n'avait pas toute la ville
mais que certains us certains quartiers
il est dans l'outrance et souvent ce
qu'on lui reproche c'est ce qu'il est
dans l'outrance notre candidat ce qui
s'est passé à roubaix non après sur la
phrase je ne connais pas sûr viry
châtillon peut pas dire que viry
châtillon c'est l'afghanistan à quelques
minutes de paris c'est la seule raison
pour laquelle je porte plainte donc
voilà après on peut être paris sur notre
sujet c'est moi parce que je suis pas là
pour être toujours en désaccord au
toujours d'accord j'essaye d'être précis
et c'est un territoire que je connais en
revanche franchement à saint julien des
bois sans que ce soit moi je vais vous
dire les plus loin sur l'antre un kebab
je trouve c'est aussi une formule
maladroite franchement par contre il ya
les vrais sujets il ya des sujets de
quartier de communautarisme qui se fixe
sur les sur les zones hlm qui d'ailleurs
concentrent les problèmes c'est aussi l
urbanisme des années 70 sur les grandes
barres qu'il faut qu'on concentre à la
fois la pauvreté et des questions
migratoires en même temps donc lé 2 et
qui fait qu'on a des problèmes de trafic
de drogue et tout ce qui se passe dans
l'espoir il dans le monde voilà donc il
ya aussi s'était jamais lancé pour cette
raison qu'on se bat justement au
quotidien tout le monde se bat au
quotidien pour faire ça moi je suis élu
je ne me suis pas fait élire pour juste
parade et je suis élu pour essayer
d'apporter des solutions je sais je suis
élu pour apporter des solutions et ces
solutions on les trouve petit à petit je
suis arrivé avec une pile y avait une
police municipale de cinq personnes à
viry-châtillon il y en a 20 c'est un
début pour une ville de 30 mille
habitants y avait pas de caméra parce
que mes fesses 17h était absolument
opposé à la vidéo protection il y en a
une trentaine y en aura 30 dans les cinq
ans qui vont venir ce sont des progrès
on les fait petit à petit on les fait
avec nos moyens parce que les moyens les
moyens c'est pas juste de le juste le
l'argent ce n'est pas juste les impôts
c'est pas juste les dotations les
subventions c'est aussi tout le coeur
qu'on y met et tout le coeur qu'on y met
pour les pour les habitants c'est bien
là que c'est le plus important si je
peux rebondir dessus moi je pense qu'en
fait il ya un problème souhait de juste
mesure c'est à dire qu'il ya tellement
de dénis dans notre pays sur ce qui se
passe dans les quartiers tellement dénis
et on voit donc sur les gens qui portent
plainte parce que jan mucha dit qu'ils
avaient des musulmans dans les hlm et
que c'est un crime ce serait une insulte
dire qu'à des musulmans dans la chaîne
mc comme eux qui le disent les offices
hlm
et entre ça et redorer si vous voulez le
problème c'est que entre ce que fait
monsieur vilain à viry châtillon qui
travaille sur sa ville et donc
effectivement contre travail sur une
ville on n'a pas envie d'être mis dans
le même sac que d'autres villes où par
contre le communautarisme va plein on
pourrait vous parler de melun enfin il
ya beaucoup de sujets où les élus sont
complètement dans la complicité avec les
islamistes mais entre dire tout va bien
et fr le déni voyez donc en fac tivement
eric zemmour il il faut ouvrir les yeux
donc après une formule qui peut être
excessive à droite ou à gauche mais par
rapport à au déni qui font qu'on est
dans la situation actuelle
et auquel il essaie de réveiller moi
j'essaye de le voir plutôt le côté on se
réveille on regarde la réalité en face
résidence améliorée chez vous je crois
mais si vous voulez quand vous êtes
président 50 ans mais si vous voulez on
est en face sur des petites phrases on
est sur du pro sur six jours est vrai le
projet de la filmer lozès la somme non
non moi je suis
parent je suis prêt à tout entendre et
je comprends qu'on puisse dire les
choses je suis opposé moi complètement à
cette façon un peu politicienne de la
langue de bois je dis les choses et
quand je les dis je les pense et je les
ai je les ai chevillée au corps sauf que
on ne dit pas une petite fera quand on
est président la république on doit
faire autre chose que de faire un
mauvais mot juste pour faire du buzz et
là c'était faire du buzz c'est non
seulement c'est faire du buzz mais en
plus il ne connaît pas le territoire un
président de la république doit
connaître les territoires et finissent
pas sûr vu les chefs renommés mais dire
c'est le mode survie et châtillon c'est
faire preuve de légèreté c'est ça c'est
le minimum que je puisse le lui
reprocher c'est faire preuve de légèreté
pour tous les habitants justement qui y
habitent et qui se sentent vraiment
agressé par une phrase pareille
d'ailleurs y'a midi qui nous dit
pardonnez moi ce que j'aime dans les
quartiers c'est cette solidarité qu'on
ne retrouve pas ailleurs on est tous
soudés faut arrêter de stigmatiser les
hlm et venir voir comment ça se passe
vraiment alors question est ce que eric
zemmour est allé voir comment ça se
passait dans ces quartiers dont il parle
d'abord il ya quand même grandir
seine-saint-denis nos forces qui connaît
le territoire pour d'autres mais je peux
revenir aussi sur la phrase que vous
venez de citer le verset quelque chose
qui nous fatiguent cerqueux
il y aurait coûte dans les quartiers que
les gens seraient solidaires certains
les campagnes oui
car si
dans les quartiers la solidarité dans
les zones pavillonnaires et la
solidarité dans les zones rurales et des
solidarités donc oui les quartiers c'est
pas tout blanc est tout noir on est
d'accord sur les quatre échelles médias
comme de graves problèmes ce que veut
dire c'est qu'on soit obligés d'attendre
un reportage sur m6 pour découvrir ce
que tout le monde sait dans beaucoup de
quartiers jeudi il ya quand même rien
qu'à les faits samuel m'a considéré ces
commerces commencé commerce peuvent-ils
être ouvert mais comment je dois pas
comment on peut tout faire des amalgames
le problème il est sur la malienne et
sur la mort le problème sur les
finalités des mots quand on dit des mots
pareil quand on considère qu'une ville
quelle qu'elle soit d'ailleurs que ce
soit violée chez psion une autre on ne
peut pas dire viry-châtillon ou telle
ville c'est l'aghanistan l'afghanistan
c'est les talibans c'est les talibans en
plus c'est pas c'est pas anodin comme
mousse et des gens qui coupe la tête des
femmes c'est les gens qui les excite
c'est des gens qui les empêchent de
vivre c'est pas jerry châtillon c'est
pas les villes en france et à un moment
donné il faut aussi on peut dire la
vérité on peut dire tout ce que certains
ne pensent pas certes ce que certains
pensaient et voudrait qu voudrait
entendre mais il faut faire attention à
ce que ça soit la vérité est là ce n'est
pas la vérité et quand on ne dit pas la
vérité ça veut dire qu'on est un menteur
et quand on est un un candidat à la
présidence de la république on se doit
d'avoir cette transparence ils réclament
justement la transparence le droit à la
transparence et je trouve qu'il a raison
de le dire je trouve qu'ils magique je
trouve qu'il avait je ne veux dire sauf
qu'il n'a pas le droit il n'a pas le
droit de dire tout et n'importe quoi
juste pour dire je peux dire je peux le
dire moi je vous dire ce qui me choque
beaucoup plus par exemple c'est le plus
youn mans 2-2 dernière brad qui en fait
des tonnes maintenant que les contre
l'islamisme et qui se prend en photo et
qui va visiter de façon très cordiale la
mosquée salam d'ambérieu en bugey alors
que cette mosquée accueil des
prédicateurs comme à l'oseille amin qui
prône la mort des homosexuels et des
mécréants qui acceptent mosquée accueil
mort à damas qui nie la responsabilité
humaine meira à toulouse quand il parle
des personnes de la mosquée emilie gourd
us à nantua damien abad qui dit oui sur
des gens qui portent les valeurs de la
république alors que ces milieux russes
à l'islamisme militant de la turquie qui
veut conquérir l'europe si vous voulez
il ya aussi des responsabilités d'élu de
clarifier leur position donc ça si vous
voulez partir de clientélisme dans nos
jeux je parle si vous voulez que entre
une phrase peut être maladroite et on
pourra s'accorder et des gens qui
soutiennent des islamistes qui vont
aller visiter et qu'ils se prennent en
photo avec eux et qui après au moment
des élections font des effets de manche
pour dire qu'ils luttent contre eux moi
ça me choque beaucoup ça vous choque
l'avenir nous dira pas non plus d'avoir
d'avoir été un petit peu dans tout les
crémeries delà du monde polique du monde
politique comme ça et puis qu'un jour
vous décidiez que ça soit zemmour le bon
candidat mais à un moment donné faut
aussi être se regarder un petit peu sur
fos faut se regarder un petit peu vous
avez participé à beaucoup d'élections
internes externes n'y en a aucune que
vous avez gagné c'est peut-être pas pour
rien c'est peut-être pas pour rien les
gens un moment donné il faut il faut il
faut là par les verts et la gauche
j'appelle pas la personne se disait
soucieux de sa santé avec moi je moi je
revendique les choses je suis je fais
partie du continu du parti les
centristes des remords à je soutient
valérie pécresse pour ces élections
concédé lection présidentielle et je
considère je continue de penser que si
eric zemmour assez assez assez signature
c'est normal qu'ils puissent défendre
ses idées et puisse défendre c'est comme
ça mais je le répète je veux tu dire je
me suis dit tout haut ce que beaucoup
pensent tout bas parce que c'est souvent
une petite phrase une petite musique
qu'on entend qu'est ce que vous répondez
jeu je dis simplement qu'il faut juste
vérifier que ce qu'il dit même si c'est
tout il faut que ça soit la vérité et
s'il était venu à viry-châtillon un jour
j'aurais pu lui faire visiter et
j'aurais pu lui montrer que le travail
qu'on fait et la vigne de viry châtillon
c'est bien loin des tailles blanc et de
l'afghanistan est ce que ça sera ma
dernière question de masse qui est ce
que votre candidat ne voit qu avec un
prisme effectivement voilà
il est accusé de maths et français les
uns contre les autres ce qu'il n'est pas
effectivement dans l'amalgamé l'outrance
et c'est ce qu'on lui reproche en
revient ma première question ça je pense
que vraiment cette histoire de cliver de
monter les français les uns contre les
autres et cetera c'est vraiment de la
deûle éléments de langage de la gauche
alors moi je suis déçu que quand la
droite républicaine moi j'ai pas
d'ennemi à droite donc je veux dire la
droite qui se dit républicaine terre et
l'air les roches france républicaine au
sens les républicains ou les centristes
qui m'avait d'ailleurs au moins eu
m'avaient soutenu dr municipal dans
cette partie mais elle soutenu et
monsieur maurage le remercie encore ici
à ça près du passé qu'on dise qu'une
personne comme eric zemmour qui veulent
août et contre qui contre les gens qui
coupe la tête de samuel pâtit on dit
c'est diviser les français sert qu'en
fait lutter contre les terroristes et
diviser les français moi je pense qu'au
contraire 70 % des français disent qu'on
a été trop loin dans la politique
migratoire c'est pas pour ça qu'ils vont
voter pour eric zemmour on est d'accord
mais sur cette position il est
majoritaire donc il est majoritaire dans
le pays ils représentaient majorité
effet précisé non mais c'est précisément
sur cette position d'arrêter totalement
l'immigration en provenance d'afrique et
du moyen-orient qu'on lui dit qui
clivent alors qu'il est en phase là
dessus avec la majorité des français
donc je veux dire c'est aussi une
confusion bien ne pas faire venir des
voix là dessus après on peut parler du
style mais sur le fond ce nom mais c'est
pas du style moi je ne trouve tellement
jeu pour pour faire du buzz c'est tout
candy des phrases aussi du mal à les
vaincre a aussi cacher est aussi devenu
d'un charter sinon parce que c'est la
réalité ça
je mange je pense on arrive à la fin de
ce débat merci messieurs en tout cas
thomas vos skis jean-marie vilain
d'avoir été avec nous et au delà des
ligues zemmour d'autres candidats à la
présidentielle alerte sur l'islamisation
de la société française c'est notamment
le cas de marine le pen et fabien
roussel écouté
il y a un lien évident entre l'explosion
de l'insécurité et ses vagues
d'immigration que nous subissons par
vague continue cette immigration hors
contrôle transforme nos rues nos
quartiers nos villages
zone de non france elle installe chez
nous des modes de vie qui ne sont pas
les nôtres elle exige des accommodements
qui sont en réalité pour nous français
la marque d'un reniement culturel elle
se traduit par des revendications
communautaristes incessantes c'est le
communautarisme qui s'installe et qui
fait le lit de l'islamisme
oui il ya en france une menace issues de
réseaux terroristes islamistes nous ne
devons pas céder d'un pouce à toutes
leurs tentatives et parfois insidieuse
je propose de taper au porte-monnaie des
organisations islamistes alors laissez
mise à sion la france la laïcité des
thèmes de campagne privilégiée par les
uns quasi ignoré parfois par les autres
on en parle avec eric revel historia
liste rt france bonsoir eric revel même
s'il est avec nous alors cette question
de l'islamisation on voit qu'elle
déchaîne en tout cas n'imagine pas la
chose oui est ce qu'elle faisait
toujours avec ces sujets là est ce
qu'elle est finalement toujours l'un des
grands enjeux de la campagne parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat
peut-être un peu moins de ses sujets
aujourd'hui oui vous avez raison quand l
exeo mourir entrée en campagne il a mis
sur la table le thème de l'immigration
est d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens ont pris
position sur ce thème alors on l'a
entendue dans ce débat mais aussi des
gens de gauche j'ai vous donner deux
exemples manuel valls ancien premier
socialiste avait publié une tribune dans
le figaro où il disait à l'époque stop
au regroupement familial
donc ça veut dire que manuel valls
anciens premiers ministres socialistes
prenaient très au sérieux la question
migratoire michel barnier qui étaient
présents dans là primaire républicain
mais qui est un gaulliste social avait
eu cette formule il faut que la france
recouvre sa souveraineté migratoire
tient de nouveau ce thème en début de
campagne était présent et puis je vais
vous donner un autre exemple peut-être
le plus frappant qui essuient d'un
géographe christophe guilluy qui avait
publié ce livre la france périphérique
et qui avait dit dans une interview au
point quelque chose d'absolument
surprenant sans doute pour quelqu'un de
gauche ils avaient dit les classes
moyennes nous on a longtemps parlé de la
question migratoire ou de la société
multiculturelle mais nous n'avons pas
voulu les entendre
donc ça veut dire que en début de
campagne eric zemmour avait visé juste
n'obligez ont finalement toute la classe
politique française c'était pratiquement
le seul candidat vraiment déclaré à ce
moment là à se positionner sur la
question migratoire
s'est pas mentir puisque j'entendais vos
invités qui parlait de mensonges et de
vérité c'est pas mentir que de dire que
certains quartiers dans certaines villes
ont été
totalement investie par l'islam
politique ce n'est pas un mensonge c'est
une réalité maintenant aujourd'hui vous
avez raison stéphanie il me semble et
d'ailleurs zemmour a fait un virage sur
l'ale à son meeting de lille samedi
dernier en fait ce qui l'a mis en avant
c'est le thème du pouvoir d'achat parce
que encore une fois dans tous les
sondages d'opinion qui interroge les
français la question du pouvoir d'achat
arrivent en numéro un suivi de la
question de la sécurité puis la question
de l'immigration d'ailleurs la question
de la sécurité ou les sens du but plus
de 60% des français considèrent que la
situation sécuritaire en france ne s'est
pas améliorée ces cinq dernières années
donc c'est un vrai sujet pour le miso
l'intérieur gérald darmanin mais c'est
un vrai sujet aussi pour le président
macron qui va être candidat à sa propre
succession alors oui pardonnez moi je
faisais coupé mais l'islamisation en
parler c'est un sujet on l'a vu que dont
s'est emparé essentiellement la droite
avec parfois quelques surenchère même
oui parce que vous avez un match du côté
de la droite nationale entre eric
zemmour et marine le pen ça n'a échappé
à personne
7cette mouvement ce mouvances politiques
représentent environ 28 à 30 % quand la
main ce qui n'a jamais été aussi haut en
france donc on peut avoir deux
considérations différentes on peut
considérer que c'est parce que les
hommes ou les femmes politiques mettent
des thèmes politiques sur la table que
les français y adhèrent ou au contraire
et c'est plutôt ma position parce que
les français considèrent que ces thèmes
sont importants et que les femmes ou les
hommes politiques qui les portent
méritent qu'on les écoute moi je n'ai
jamais cru si vous voulez que des thèmes
descendait comme ça d'un programme d'un
candidat et que les français y
adhéraient si ça ne correspondait pas à
leurs réalités
donc le thème migratoire n'en déplaise à
plein de bonnes âmes c'est un thème qui
inquiète les français d'ailleurs je vous
rappelle que valéry giscard d'estaing
ancien président république française
qui avait opté pour le regroupement
familial avait exprimé un jour le fait
qu'il avait sans doute commis une erreur
on en est dans cette situation et as
dans cette situation là on est à ce
point là maintenant ce qu'on veut aussi
entendre une fois que manuel mâcon sera
revenu de moscou qui avait fait de
berlin c'est qu'on entende les
propositions du candidat macro notamment
sur cette question et je vous rappelle
qu'il a positionné assez haut dans
l'agenda de président du conseil
européen qui l'assument pendant six mois
emmanuel macron la question des
frontières de schengen
si la question des fontes des frontières
de schengen extérieur est abordée ça
prouve bien que le présent république
qui va devenir candidat va prendre cette
question migratoire à bras le corps et
qu'il n'en fera pas simplement d'un
revers de main une question subalterne
d'accord mais là vous parler du futur
mais enfin le passé il a déjà été
président de la république quel est son
bilan bah écoutez son bilan dès
l'instant où il veut essayer de
redéfinir peut-être les frontières de
schengen ça prouve qu'il n'est pas
satisfait de son bilan l'immigration
illégale
c'est un vrai problème en europe on le
sait via l'italie on le sait via la
grèce on le sait via l'espagne il ya des
enclaves où beaucoup de travailleurs
illégaux parfois au prix de leur vie en
traversant la méditerranée essaie de
rallier l'europe on le sait dans le nord
de la france où un centre de de migrants
illégaux et c'est de passer la manche
pour rejoindre la grande bretagne
d'ailleurs on a oublié tout ça mais il
ya quelques semaines à peine le
gouvernement britannique avait mis
solennellement en garde le gouvernement
français il ya un traité de protection
des frontières entre la france et la
grande bretagne et le gouvernement
britannique par la voix de boris johnson
et sa mise l'intérieur qui lui succédera
peut-être avait dit si vous continuez
les français de laisser passer des
bateaux avec des migrants qui traversent
la manche pour aller en grande bretagne
nous ferons ce qu'on appelle du push
back c'est à dire que nous repousserons
ces bateaux pour que vous vous les
accueillir en france donc ce sujet de
l'immigration au-delà de la polémique
politicienne des extravagances des
outrances des uns et des autres c'est un
thème central pour l'europe évidemment
pour la france et je vois pas comment au
delà la question du pouvoir d'achat on
pourra faire l'économie dans les débats
de la présidentielle de traiter ce sujet
la plupart des candidats en tout cas
déjà bien compris certainement merci
eric revel et c'est la fin de cette
émission on se retrouve demain 20h pour
un nouveau numéro excellente soirée est
offerte et france
[Musique]
de tous les départements français aucun
n'est peut-être aussi intrigant et
méconnue que ce petit bout de france au
coeur de l'océan indien qu'on appelle
mayotte derrière la carte postale ce
101e département et le plus pauvre de
france foyer à la rivière là il ya tout
et c'est un peu dégueulasse
meloni cavage clos
passer une tétée il me dit il n'ya même
pas de pain quand on n'a jamais donné
une compote qui est bien seul est est ce
que vous avez une idée de qui sont ces
gens qui attaquent un lycée
sapa
cinq ans
[Musique]
sakho
[Applaudissements]
veut contenir tout le monde sur l'île
évidemment que l'on est assis sur une
poudrière moi je leur jette même pas la
pierre si bien m'accueillir mais jusqu'à
saint lô leur donne de l'espoir et puis
à la fin on leur dit quoi non mais t'as
pas de papiers mais écoute accroche toi
mais j'ai pas de conneries pour une fois
qu'on a la parole aussi dit mais est-ce
que ce qu'on leur a apporté est ce que
ce système là ce qu'il est bon pour moi
le gros point d'interrogation
exception française sentiment d'être
oubliés qui sont ces habitants qui
vivent à 8000 kilomètres de l'hexagone
est content il à nous dire entre
grandeur et misère nous sommes allés à
leur rencontre
[Musique]
m
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec comme invité
cette semaine
johanna le pape bonjour on a une chance
parce que vous êtes une rare d'abord
c'est une des stars de la gastronomie
française n'y a pas beaucoup de femmes
dans la gastronomie depuis notamment
dans la pâtisserie que c'est ça votre
votre couloir de nage comme on dit un
peu hein vous êtes connu un peu partout
dans le monde maintenant je me suis
aperçu de sa voix qui me soulage un peu
dans le cac 40 j'avais pas forcément
l'habitude mais j'irai vous avez acquis
votre notoriété quoi par votre talent
bien sûr mais il ya autre chose quand
même il ya eu il ya aussi une histoire
il ya un discours parce que vous avez
bouleversé un peu les codes la de la
pâtisserie j'espère que je ne vous
choque pas en disant ça la pâtisserie
pour tout le monde sait c'est quand même
du sucre en gros et qu'on a l'habitude
de servir à la fin d'un repas comme
récompense et vous vous êtes arrivé si
j'ai bien compris en disant oui mais la
pâtisserie ça doit aussi respecter les
aspects n'utilisera nutritionnelle
alors on va regarder ça en détail pour
pourtant vous avez donc milité pour une
pâtisserie j'allais dire une pâtisserie
politique quoi engager
compatibles avec les contraintes du
bien-être
alors je sais pas comment vous l'avez
fait sais pas pourquoi et c'est ça qui
fait tilt qui nous intéresse comment ça
démarre l'aventuré johanna le pape se
remet ça démarre dans un restaurant qui
est des flux par ses parents ou pas mais
pas du tout cela démarre depuis les
terrains de basket en fait puisque c'est
là où j'ai commencé le basket en
bretonne exactement le wes cates après
du coup je suis danger poursuit